Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's a Prof?
Hi Walter. Hi Martin.
Are you ready for this one?
I don't think anybody can ever be ready
for this one. It's too big.
And it's the most important messages
that has to be proclaimed to the world.
The final messages
to the world. It's a make or break
situation.
So, let's open with a word of prayer.
Our heavenly Father, it's a privilege to
work for you.
But our enemy is walking around like a
roaring lion trying to devour everybody.
So, we ask that you
bless us,
protect us, and enlighten our minds that
we can give this presentation and this
talk according to your will. And we ask
that in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Fear God and give glory to him.
And I saw another angel.
Martin,
these are the final messages to
humanity.
And uh
they are
a unit with the whole book of
Revelation.
Especially very important Revelation 11,
12, 13, 14. This is where the messages
are.
16, 17
gives the milieu in which they take
place, the political situation,
the philosophical situation. Revelation
chapter 11
is the philosophical situation that set
up the current paradigms that are active
in the world. The new situations, the
getting rid of the kings, bringing in
democracy, bringing in the philosophy
that goes along with it, the philosophy
of the French Revolution, Voltaire,
Robespierre, all of these philosophies.
And in the midst of this boiling
cauldron, there is a message from God.
And for a while the French banned the
Bible
during this whole tumultuous period. And
then they stood up and they were to
bring a message on the Old and the New
Testament together. The two witnesses
must talk about these things. And then
there is this final war against the
remnant, and the remnant must bring a
message to every people and nation and
tribe and
and kingdom and tongue. Everybody on the
whole earth must hear this message
because the world
is in rebellion against God.
And here's a final call.
And it's a very urgent call.
And it started, of course, sequentially
as you go through the book of
Revelation, there is a historic
continuum.
A time period, the prophecies of the
1,260
days,
the period of papal supremacy during the
Middle Ages, which ended with the
abolishment of the papal states and the
political power which they wielded. But
it didn't actually stop. It seemed to
have a mortal wound. So, in 1798,
the Pope was taken captive and people
were very alert as to things that are
happening, but they went underground.
And they, through their secret
societies, set up a political system
that was steeped with religious aspects,
but they didn't bring them to the fore
because state and church were separated.
And then the Bible tells us that these
powers that be will bring back a system
that is an image of what it was in the
Middle Ages. So, church and state must
come back together.
And the legislations that will be passed
once religious laws are enforced again,
and that is a pendulum swing. We've
spoken about that many, many times. Once
that takes place, Martin, and church and
state comes together, there is a loud
message that has to go out, a message of
warning.
And then you had the prophecy of Daniel
8 and 9,
where you had the 2,300-day
prophecy,
and the time periods involved in that,
and that ended in 1844.
We've discussed these prophecies many,
many times. We don't have time to go
into that. And during this culmination
of that prophecy, the final message of
warning has to go out to humanity. And
that's the three angels' messages. And
they are sequential.
So, there is the first angel.
If the first angel is rejected by the
majority of humanity, then there is a
second angel.
And then there is a final message. And
then there is an ultimate final message
that takes them all together and gives
the final warning, the loud cry,
and warns people that if they continue
in their rebellion, there will be
consequences.
So, that's what it's about. So, let's
look at these messages and see what we
can glean.
Number one, it is the most important
message or messages that have to go to
the world.
Because they're the final warning. And
it contains everything. Everything. It
contains from Genesis 1 till Revelation
22, the whole Bible.
It's got the everlasting gospel, but
we'll get to that. But every single
thing in the Bible is actually
encapsulated in these three.
And it's a it's phenomenal how in just a
few verses
you can have so much depth. You you
cannot exhaust it. It will be a study of
a lifetime, of eternity.
So, let's have a look what the reformers
believed about
these messages as they are in the Bible.
Of course, they didn't have a full
understanding of these issues because
they still had to unfold.
To many these things were future.
Exactly. The time of the 1,260
days or years was not finished yet. The
2,300 was not finished yet. All of that
had to still happen.
So, let's look at what John Wesley had
to say about these messages. And I saw
another another angel.
A second is mentioned, Revelation 14:8.
A third is mentioned, Revelation 14:9.
So, the reformers thought about these
things. And this is Wesley. He's a
little bit later than Luther and all of
these. So, time had progressed. There
were new situations, the new continents
had been discovered and had been
colonated, etc.
And then he says, "These three denote
great messengers of God with their
assistance."
Three men who bring messages from God to
men. He thought it was men.
The first exhorts to the fear and
worship of God.
The second proclaims the fall of
Babylon.
The third gives warning concerning the
beast. Happy are they who make the right
use of these divine messages.
Flying,
going on swiftly in the midst of heaven,
in
the breadth ways, everywhere. The
message is universal.
Having an everlasting gospel. And then
he sums this up. He says, "Not the
gospel properly so called,
but a gospel or joyful message which was
to have an influence on all ages,
to preach to every nation and tribe and
tongue and people, both to Jew and
Gentile, even as far as the authority of
the beast has extended." Now, we must
know that these reformers had a very
clear understanding as to who the beast
was. All of them said it was
the Roman system, the Roman Catholic
system.
From the time of Luther, Melanchthon,
Calvin, all the reformers, including
John Wesley, were very clear on the
issue
that the beast was Roman Catholicism.
So, as far as that influence stretched,
and that was universal, so far did the
three angels' messages have to go.
That was their understanding.
It it needs to be tweaked a little bit,
but we can look at that.
If we go to the book The Great
Controversy,
it says the work of preaching the gospel
has not been committed to angels,
but has been entrusted to men.
Holy angels have been employed in
directing this work. They have in charge
the great movements for salvation of
men,
but the actual proclamation of the
gospel is performed by the servants of
Christ upon the earth.
Uh that is a
axiom right throughout the scriptures.
So, angels are involved. Gabriel goes
and reports to Daniel. Daniel is the
prophet. He takes the message to the
world. Uh the people of God study the
message and repeat it to whoever. That's
how it works. God uses people
to reach people.
And and that's really quite an amazing
thing about God, huh? It's an amazing
thing about God, and also must tell you
something about humans. Yes. He really
values
humans.
Yes. Uh to such an extent that he became
one. Yeah.
But, we'll go into that.
So, the question is who is to bring this
final message of warning to the world?
It's very important that we know who
brings the message. Mhm.
Because not everybody out there is
preaching about the three angels.
No.
Wesley preached about it. He didn't have
a full understanding of what they were.
He knew certain components,
but his followers are not saying peep.
No. Not one word. That's the thing.
There's a lot of messages out there, but
not this message.
Okay. So, the Protestant churches out
there, the general Protestant world is
not preaching this message.
So, let's have a look. Revelation 12:17.
And the dragon was wroth with the woman.
That's the church.
And went to make war with the remnant of
her seed. Now, if you put that into
prophetic context,
then uh it has to do with the 1,260-day
prophecy, which stretches from 538 AD,
when the papal power assumed political
clout,
to the time when it was abolished in
1798.
And during that time of authority, God's
church prophesied in sackcloth.
They didn't have the Bible.
They were hounded. If they tried to do
what the Bible and the scriptures said,
they were eradicated. They were
persecuted.
They were brought before the
Inquisition. They were in sackcloth.
After 1798,
uh they were released from those
shackles.
And the whole political system changed,
as we said. In those days, church and
state
was dictating everything.
Yes.
So, now this woman that had been
persecuted, then had gone to the wilder-
wilderness, was the Protestant church
that preached the Bible, but wasn't
allowed to do it under that system.
And then out of her would come a
remnant. So, this remnant must arise
after the close of that prophetic
period, 1798. And they have certain
criteria.
Yes.
Because that's a remnant of her seed.
So, in other words, it must be a
Bible-based
organization
or group.
And their attributes are that they keep
the commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ.
That's their attributes.
Well, like you said, that is the
criteria. You have to end both of it.
Yes. Doesn't have help if you have only
one and stand on one leg. Right. They
must have the testimony of Jesus, and
they must keep the commandments of God.
So, let's ask what is the testimony of
Jesus? We find it in Revelation 19, from
verse 9 onwards. And he said unto me,
"Write, blessed are they which are
called unto the marriage supper of the
Lamb."
So, Martin, we have a time frame. This
must be just before the coming of
Christ, because there's a call to the
marriage supper.
So, this is an end-time message. And he
said unto me, "These are the true
sayings of God." And I fell at his feet
to worship him.
So, John falls at the feet of the angel,
but the angel raises him up and says,
"Don't do it. You must worship God."
He said, "See that thou do it not, for I
am thy fellow servant and of thy
brethren that have
the testimony of Jesus."
You must worship God.
For the testimony of Jesus is the spirit
of prophecy. So, the prophetic gift Yes.
must be part and parcel of this remnant.
That's it. So, we have two aspects. They
keep the commandments of God, and they
have the prophetic gift. They have the
spirit of prophecy.
That's what they must have.
That's what they must have. So, they
must be Bible-based.
They must believe in Jesus Christ as
Lord, because they have the testimony of
Jesus. So, they're Christian
organization.
It's not rocket science.
And this criteria for even like you
mentioned, the prophetic gift has got
criteria. So, not every Tom, Dick, and
Harry
or Tom, Dick, and Jane can be a prophet.
They have to adhere to the criteria.
Okay.
Now, this was prophesied
that there would be an outpouring of
God's spirit, and that the prophetic
gifts would be manifested again.
And we find that in the book of Joel,
from in chapter 2, from verse 28. And it
shall come to pass afterwards,
that I will pour out my spirit upon all
flesh, and your sons and daughters shall
prophesy. Your old men shall shall dream
dreams. Your young men shall see
visions.
So, there will be a manifestation of the
power of God
at the end of time. And also, upon the
servants and upon the handmaids in those
days will I pour out my spirit.
So, there's no gender discrimination
here. It can be on males and on females.
And I will show wonders in the heaven
and in the earth, blood and fire and
pillars of smoke.
The sun shall be turned into darkness
and the moon into blood before the great
and terrible day of the Lord
come.
Now, those were physical manifestations
that would take place,
and they
actually did, because we had the dark
day
in New England, and we had the terrible
earthquake, and all of these precursors.
We're not going into all of those
prophetic details now, because we want
to concentrate on the message. But,
these things actually happened. So, they
set the time frame.
And it shall come to pass that whosoever
shall call on the name of the Lord shall
be delivered.
So,
here is a condition.
You have to come back into harmony with
God,
and you have to call on the name of the
Lord.
In other words, you must be
Christ-centered. You must know what the
plan of salvation is.
For in Mount Zion and in Jerusalem shall
be deliverance, as the Lord has said,
and in the remnant
whom the Lord shall call.
So, there'll be a remnant.
What are the conditions surrounding this
remnant, Martin? Keep the commandments
and have the faith of Jesus.
And the faith of Jesus is? The spirit of
prophecy. Right.
So, there's a very specific group at the
end of time.
It's a remnant.
They have very specific identification
features.
They are Christian,
because they call on the name of the
Lord. They have the testimony of Jesus.
They have the prophetic gift in their
midst, and they keep the commandments of
God.
That's it. That's the group that will
bring the final message.
Now, who's the message to?
The whole world. The whole world.
Okay.
Now, Martin, there's a prelude to the
three angels' messages. In other words,
the portion of scripture from verse 1 in
chapter 14 to verse 5
sets the stage for the message, which
commences in verse 6.
And it deals with the 144,000.
Now, the Bible doesn't tell us who the
144,000
actually are,
but they are those that come through
this time of trouble.
And they're a symbolic number,
and we do not know who they are, so
there's no point in speculating as to
who they are.
And it says, "And I looked, and lo, a
Lamb stood on the Mount Zion, and with
him 144,000
having his Father's name written in
their foreheads."
In other words, they had come into
harmony with the character of God.
So, we can actually say they've come
into harmony with the law of God. That's
it. It is, because the character, like
we've
did in the previous one, is the law.
Okay. So, we can say that they had come
into harmony
with God's law,
and therefore reflect his character.
Now, the final message will be brought
by those who keep the commandments.
So, in other words, they must also be in
harmony
with those
requirements.
Verse 2. and I heard a voice from heaven
as the voice of many waters and as the
voice of a great thunder.
And I heard the voice of harpers harping
with their harps. And they sung as it
were a new song before the throne and
before the four beasts and the elders.
And no man could learn that song but the
144,000
which were redeemed from the earth. So,
this is a song of deliverance.
Just like the Moses had a song of
deliverance that was led by Miriam, so
here will be a song of deliverance
probably led by an antitypical Miriam.
And it will be the song of Moses and the
lamb.
And then, verse four, "These are they
which were not defiled with women."
Let's just pause there, Martin. You know
what the symbol of a woman is. We've
spoken about it.
Churches.
So, they were not defiled by churches.
In other words, they didn't receive
their doctrines
from creeds.
They received their doctrine from the
word of God. They measured
in the scale what they heard and
accepted only that which was in harmony
with God's word.
If it was conjecture, if it was based on
human reasoning,
and uh remember that the of reason has
been elevated in the French Revolution
to a level of deity because the goddess
reason was worshipped. In other words,
human thinking was placed above divine
thinking.
So, these people were not defiled by
these women, by these churches.
They sifted the message.
They were virgins.
In other words, they were not untrue.
They were not sleeping around
spiritually speaking. They were true to
the message and to the testimony of
Jesus.
And getting ready for the marriage. For
the marriage. Yes. If you take the
parable of the 10 virgins, those were
all virgins seeking for an entrance into
the kingdom. All right, these are they
which follow the lamb whithersoever he
goeth.
They don't follow a man.
They follow the lamb.
So, if a man says you must do this,
that, and the other, go and check it out
in the book.
To see if you are following the lamb or
whether you are following man.
That's a very We'll get to a very
interesting one on that, especially when
you get to the mark. Yes.
And these were redeemed from amongst
men, being the firstfruits unto God and
to the lamb. So, they had accepted the
plan of redemption. They have accepted
the atonement.
All the conditions that are connected to
the plan of salvation.
God did not remove Adam and Eve from the
Garden of Eden or remove Satan and his
host from heaven just to allow them back
in their same disobedience.
True.
Right?
Yep.
And in their mouth was found no guile.
They're not going to lie to you.
They're going to be truthful.
For they are without fault before the
throne of God. Now, the only way that
you can be without fault before the
throne of God is if you have accepted
the righteousness of Christ.
That's it.
So, they are not
without fault because they are of a
higher being than anybody else, but
because they have accepted the plan of
salvation
and have been clothed with the
righteousness of Christ.
They're not standing there on their own.
They died to self and Christ lives in
them.
So,
that's the prelude.
So, the people that give the message
must fit into this category. It's part
of the It's like yeah, it's part of the
requirement. Okay. So,
just off the bat, can you be in an
ecumenical council? No, because that
already tells you you're going to be
defiled by the woman.
Martin, you're being very forthright.
But that's what the Bible says.
is saying it, yeah. Okay. So,
yes, we have to look at these things
very carefully.
Here's another quote from the Bible
commentary. "Those who keep God's
commandments, those who live not by
bread alone, but by every word that
proceeds out of the mouth of God,
compose the church of the living God."
In other words, they follow the
blueprint, which is the Bible.
Those who choose to follow Antichrist
are subjects of the great apostate.
So, if you sit in an ecumenical council
and you accept a compromise situation,
then you are subjects of the great
apostate.
Ranged under the banner of Satan, they
break God's law and lead others to break
it. They endeavor so to frame the laws
of nations that men shall show their
loyalty to earthly governments
by trampling upon the laws of God's
kingdom. Isn't that exactly what we just
said? It's exactly and it's also exactly
what you've seen happening. Now, there
was a very interesting meeting in the
Vatican
just recently
where the whole issue of sexuality
and who is welcome in God's kingdom and
who is not was discussed.
And there were quite a number of bishops
that were up in arms at
some of the things that were coming up.
But what was being said there is being
emulated in Protestant churches as well.
Exactly. It's not nothing different.
And those are compromise issues with
issues of the world and have nothing to
do with the word of God, right? True.
So, let's just leave it there. Let's not
go any further.
So, they endeavor so to frame the laws
of nations that men shall show their
loyalty to earthly governments by
trampling upon the laws of God's
kingdom. That's what they will do. And
this is what the more warning message is
all about.
Satan is diverting minds with
unimportant questions in order that they
shall not with clear and distinct vision
see the matters of vast importance.
The enemy is planning to ensnare the
world.
And the three angels' messages are
planning to ensnare the world.
Both are going to every type and tongue
and nation. And you have to make a
choice.
So, you're going to have one message
which is going to be pumped by the media
and by the churches. And you're going to
have another message by this group.
Which will be a minority message because
it's a remnant. It's a minority message.
It's not the popular one. No.
Now, Martin, who is giving the three
angels' messages in the world? Name me a
denomination. Now, this is not pushing a
particular denomination. This is just an
assertion of fact.
Which denomination is preaching the
three angels' messages? There's no other
one than the Seventh-day Adventist
Church. Okay. So, in a special sense,
Seventh-day Adventists have been set in
the world as watchmen and light bearers.
To them has been entrusted the last
warning for a perishing world. Well, you
can test it. That's it. Ask yourself,
who is preaching the three angels'
messages? No one else is other than
Seventh-day Adventists. To them has been
entrusted the last warning for a
perishing world. On them is shining
wonderful light from the word of God.
They have been given a work of the most
solemn import, the proclamation of the
first, second, and third angels'
messages.
Again, test it. There's nobody else
that's giving it.
There is no other work of so great
importance. They are to allow nothing
else to absorb their attention. That's
supposed to be their job.
And if they are diverted and are doing
other things,
then don't listen to them. Listen to
those that are preaching the three
angels' messages because that's what the
Bible says they should be doing.
Exactly. They that adhere to
to the requirement.
Okay. So, that brings us then to the
message itself. What is the message? And
why is it so important?
And given the political and the
religious backdrop in which this takes
place
and the historic time period in which it
takes place, it's very essential that we
carefully
dissect what is written here.
Yeah.
Right, the message is start in
Revelation 14:6. "And I saw another
angel fly in the midst of heaven
having the everlasting gospel to preach
unto them that dwell on the earth, to
every nation and kindred and tongue and
people."
So, there are a few points to lift out
here.
In the midst of heaven.
Now, remember what Wesley said.
In the broadways, in the breadthways, as
he put it, it must go everywhere.
And what is the message? It's an
everlasting gospel. Exactly. So, don't
the churches preach the gospel, Martin?
Yes, they do, well, according to them.
But do they preach the everlasting
gospel or do they preach a portion of
the gospel?
Yes.
Okay, or do they preach another gospel?
Yes, that that also. Doesn't the Bible
or Paul
clearly say
that if anyone preaches another gospel,
he is accursed? Yeah. So, is it possible
that people are preaching another
gospel? That can be if not even knowing
it. All right. So, it must be very
important that the everlasting gospel
should be preached again.
And to whom? And to every nation and
kindred and tongue and people. It must
be a universal message.
Yeah.
Now, there are only two churches that
are truly universal. Yeah. Did you know
that? Mhm.
It's the Roman Catholic Church and the
Seventh-day Adventist Church. That's the
only two? They're only two.
The others are maybe broadly
represented, but only two are
universal.
Saying with a loud voice, "Fear God and
give glory to him."
"For the hour of his judgment is come."
"And worship him that made the heavens,
the earth, the sea, and the fountains of
water." So, here we have again a
breakdown.
The first part is fear God and give
glory to him. Mhm. The second part is
the hour of his judgment is come.
Mhm.
And the third part is worship him who
made
the heavens, the earth, and the sea, and
the fountains of water. Mhm.
Now,
it's an everlasting gospel.
Yeah. It's a universal gospel. And
there's a very specific message entailed
in it.
And it's all
especially the last three that we were
mentioning, or actually even the
everlasting gospel,
is pointing to the same God.
Yes, always to the same God.
All right, let's break it down.
The message is in the flying in the
midst of heaven.
Revelation 8:13,
"And I beheld an angel flying through
the midst of heaven." These are parallel
texts that we're quoting.
"Saying with a loud voice, 'Woe, woe,
woe to the inhabitants of the earth by
reason of the other voices of the
trumpet of the three angels which are
yet to sound.'"
So, here is the message of the trumpets.
Mhm. It's also a universal message in
the midst of heaven, and it's
declaration of woe. A judgment is
coming. And yeah, judgment and warning.
So, when God
pronounces
that a judgment is coming,
the message goes in the midst of heaven.
He wants everybody to know. Yeah.
Why?
Because he wants everybody to be saved.
He loves everybody. Okay.
Then you have, of course, Revelation
14:6 where the message is also flying in
the midst of heaven. Everybody is to
know.
And then you have Revelation 19:17,
"And I saw an angel standing in the sun,
and he cried with a loud voice saying to
all the fowls that fly in the midst of
heaven, 'Come and gather yourselves
together unto the supper of the great
God.'" So, here is the final judgment.
And uh
the false elements
are also flying in the midst of heaven,
but they will take part in a supper that
nobody really wants to be part of. Yes,
so
So, all of these are basically judgment
messages.
That's it. The woe, woe, woe already
tells you this.
All of them are judgment messages. And
God wants everybody to know.
So, it must be
a very prominent message.
Yeah.
And nobody is
a favorite, and nobody is excluded.
Everybody has a choice to make.
And if you make a choice that doesn't
make you better than other people,
it just means you've accepted the gospel
as it is proclaimed in the word. That's
So, the everlasting gospel. So, the word
everlasting occurs 91 times in the King
James Version.
16 times it refers to the covenant which
is everlasting.
And the other times it refers to God who
is everlasting or many, many issues.
But 16 times it refers to the covenant.
So, 1 Chronicles 16:14 says, "He is the
Lord our God, his judgments are in all
the earth.
Be you mindful always of his covenant.
The word which he commanded to a
thousand generations." The covenant
covenant is immovable. And it's all also
everlasting. It's unchangeable.
It It started in the beginning. Yes, and
it's always to do with the law. Mhm.
Then people say, "But there's a new
covenant." But the new covenant says,
"I'll write my law in your heart."
It's the same It's still the same. It's
still the same, and instead of
practicing it as a ritual, please
understand what it's about. Put it in
your heart, right?
Because God saw that it didn't help them
because they could do the ritual, but
they forgot it. Yeah, what it's all
about. So, it needs to be a heart
religion, not a do religion.
Even of the covenant which he made with
Abraham and of his oath unto Isaac.
Verse 17, "And has confirmed the same to
Jacob for a law
and to Israel for an everlasting
covenant."
So,
a covenant has to do with the law. Mhm.
You As we said in the last presentation,
you cannot separate the law and the
character of God.
And you cannot have a judgment without a
law.
Now, here's a quote from the
Fundamentals of Christian Education.
"Christ came in the form of humanity to
live the law of God.
He was the word of life. He came to be
the gospel of salvation to the world.
And to fulfill every specification of
the law.
Jesus is the word, the guidebook which
must be received and obeyed in every
particular.
How necessary that this mine of truth be
explored and the precious treasures of
truth
be discovered and secured as rich
jewels."
"The incarnation of Christ,
his divinity,
his atonement, his wonderful life in
heaven as our advocate, the office of
the Holy Spirit, all these living vital
themes of Christianity are revealed from
Genesis to Revelation."
Martin, this is what the plan of
salvation is all about, right?
That's it.
Everlasting gospel. Yes.
And it's from Genesis to Revelation. The
gospel was preached in Genesis. To To To
Adam and Eve. The promise of the Messiah
was given to Adam and Eve.
Cain and Abel received the instructions
as to how the plan of salvation works.
They had to bring a lamb which pointed
to Jesus Christ, which had to be
sacrificed.
Well, even Adam and Eve had to sacrifice
the lamb. And Cain decided, "No, his own
works were good enough."
Yeah.
So, this is the battle between faith and
works, which has existed from the
beginning. It's amazing. So, if you take
the first angel's message, tells you the
everlasting gospel. The gospel was
already given to Adam and Eve. Nothing
has changed.
The golden links of truth form a chain
of evangelical truth.
"In the first and staple is found the
great teachings of Christ Jesus. Why
then
should not the scriptures be ennobled
and exalted in every school in our land?
How little children are educated to
study the Bible as the word of God and
feed upon its truths, which are the
flesh and blood of the Son of God?"
Mhm. Haven't Bibles been removed,
Martin? Yeah.
"Except you eat the flesh of the Son of
man and drink his blood, you have no
life in you." If we do not understand
the scriptures and base our
understanding on the scriptures, we will
be led astray.
"Whoso eateth my flesh and drinketh my
blood" that is, continues to receive the
words of Christ and practice them
"has eternal life.
And I will raise him up at the last day,
for my flesh is meat indeed, and my
blood is drink indeed. He that eateth my
flesh and drinketh my blood dwelleth in
me, and I in him. He that keepeth his
commandments dwelleth in him, and he in
him. And hereby we know that he abideth
in us by the Spirit which he has given
us."
It's
plain and direct.
That's why the remnant will be
keeping to the commandments and have the
faith of Jesus, which is the spirit of
prophecy. This is
tells you exactly the same. Why was
Satan and his host thrown out of heaven?
Because they rebelled against They were
didn't want to keep the commandments,
and they were rebelling against Jesus.
Okay.
So, they refused to obey God. He coveted
the position of God.
He coveted that position
next to the throne,
and therefore he broke the 10th
commandment.
And thereby he broke the first, and
having broken one, he became a murderer
and a liar. He broke them all. Yeah.
Okay. Why were Adam and Eve removed from
the Garden of Eden? The same reason.
Because of disobedience. They wanted a
higher learning and a higher standing
than they had before. So, it's the same
principle. Yeah. It was coupled to a
fruit, which was a small thing. That's
how it should be. Yeah, but it was a
much bigger concept.
Concept.
Wanting to be something that had not
been granted to you from the beginning.
Yeah.
All right, so this gives you a backdrop.
So then if you take we've got that
portion that we mentioned it's the same
God in the first angels
um that we have to give the honor to.
So obviously if you read this that is
Jesus Christ. Must be.
So law and grace cannot be separated.
It is only by the imputed and imparted
righteousness of Christ that man can be
saved.
The cross is the guarantee that the law
is immutable and our salvation lies in
the blood of the lamb.
Once you separate law and grace
you run into a major problem.
Mhm. Because you don't have a basis for
judgment, you don't have a
basis for fairness. It's You don't have
a criteria for living your life
according to God's direction. So you
have to stand on both legs. If you stand
on only one you'll be lame. Yes.
Now Martin
people say well if you're keeping the
law then that's legalism.
It depends if you're keeping the law to
be saved
or if you're keeping the law because
you're saved. That's the difference.
difference.
So here's a quote from faith and works.
He who is trying to reach heaven by his
own works in keeping the law is
attempting an impossibility.
Man cannot be saved without obedience
but his works should not be of himself.
Christ should work in him to will and to
do of his good pleasure.
If a man could save himself by his own
works he might have something in himself
in which to rejoice.
The effort that man makes in his own
strength to obtain salvation is
represented by the offering of Cain.
Isn't that what we just said?
All that man can do without Christ is
polluted with selfishness and sin.
But that which is wrought through faith
is acceptable to God.
When we seek to gain heaven through the
merits of Christ the soul makes progress
looking unto Jesus the author and
finisher of our faith.
We may go from strength to strength from
victory to victory for through Christ
the grace of God has worked out our
complete salvation. So salvation is
Christ-centered. That's it. It doesn't
exclude obedience however because Christ
working in you will produce obedience.
It will and like we did in that
uh
lecture of the character of God
if you his law is his character. So
obviously when you have the grace of
Christ and the righteousness of Christ
you will reflect that character which is
keeping the law. So basically what we
are doing now is we're saying what is
the everlasting gospel? We
we're giving that a description. Yes,
correct. Okay.
The second part is that it has to go to
every nation, kindred, tongue, and
people. People must understand that
there is a plan of salvation. There is a
rescue plan.
Now Martin just imagine this.
The law was broken in heaven.
And those who broke it refused to
repent. They lost their position in
heaven.
Right?
Adam and Eve were given an opportunity.
They broke it.
But they were deceived.
Yes.
And so God in his compassion looked upon
them and knew that the law condemned
them to death.
And now
how are they going to be saved?
Because justice demanded the death of
the transgressor.
So God himself
decided to bear the consequences.
And imagine the sinless Christ
he who had no propensity
towards sin
condescending
to become a human being.
Taking him upon himself humanity.
But without sin.
The Bible is very clear. He was without
sin. He was without the propensity to
sin.
And yet he was prepared to take the
consequences of sin.
The sin of every individual that should
ever live upon himself.
And the consequences are death.
But the consequences bring mental
anguish and they bring physical anguish.
And he was mutilated on our behalf but
he was prepared to do that.
And through his blood and through his
stripes we can obtain salvation because
the price had been fully paid.
Yeah. The consequences the the the
penalty for transgressing the law. But
what was the condition?
Death.
You had to accept his atonement.
yeah. Right? You had to accept his
atonement and you received the
instruction go and sin no more. Mhm. Do
not transgress the law.
And I will help you. I will work in you.
You need to
die to self. The old man must die daily
and Christ will work within you the
works that only he is capable of doing.
That's the plan of salvation. That's the
everlasting gospel. That's the good
news. Mhm. But the price is dying to
self.
Yeah.
And giving Christ letting him work
through you. Now the message also has to
go to every nation, kindred, and tongue.
To the prophet Isaiah were given
glorious revelations of the ultimate
restoration of God's people.
Referring to the time of the end.
There must be a restoration. Yeah.
So obviously something went awry.
A gospel that was limping was introduced
to the humanity. Obedience was taken out
of it. Or the law was changed.
So that you were basing your salvation
on another Christ who didn't keep those
commandments but another set of
commandments. Doesn't make sense.
Isaiah 56:6 also the sons of the
stranger
that join themselves to the Lord to
serve him and to love the name of the
Lord to be his servants everyone that
keepeth the Sabbath from polluting it
and taketh hold of my covenant.
Uh did it only apply to Israel or the
stranger as well?
Strangers so that means every single
person. Did it entail the Sabbath?
Yeah, very prominent.
So does it entail the whole of the 10
commandments?
Yeah. Okay because that's the covenant,
isn't it? Yeah.
Verse 7, even them will I bring to my
holy mountain and make them joyful in my
house of prayer. Their burnt offerings
and their sacrifices will be accepted
upon mine altar.
For mine house shall be called a house
of prayer for all people.
Must they all keep the Sabbath? All.
Now the burnt offering that is
acceptable isn't that Jesus Christ on
the cross?
Yeah.
And not keep their own dictates. Not
their own Sabbath.
God's Sabbath. Correct because it says
that keepeth the Sabbath from polluting
it.
The Lord God which gathereth the
outcasts of Israel says yet will I
gather others to him besides those that
are gathered unto him. It's going to be
a universal message. So here's a
proclamation that everybody in the whole
world
will have to hear this message.
Martin here's another quote from
Prophets and Kings. This glorious light
of the world
was to bring salvation to every nation,
kindred, tongue, and people.
Of the work before him the prophet heard
the eternal Father declare it is a light
thing that thou shouldst be my servant
to raise up the tribes of Jacob and to
restore the preserved of Israel.
I will also give thee for a light to the
Gentiles that thou mayest be my
salvation unto the ends of the earth.
It's a universal message.
And it's not once again it's not only
for one nation or one
people.
Gentiles, Jews and not favorite
all.
Must the Hindus hear it?
Yes. Must the Muslims hear it? Everyone.
Must the Jews hear it?
Yes.
Have the Jews rejected Jesus as the
Messiah?
Yes. Yes.
Do the Hindus have Jesus as their
Messiah? No.
Do the Muslims have him as their
Do the Buddhists have him as their
Messiah? No. Must they hear this
message? Every single one. Yes, but what
does the Pope say? No, don't
proselytize. Uh-huh.
So in an acceptable time have I heard
thee and in the day of salvation have I
helped thee. I will preserve thee and
give thee for a covenant of the people
to establish the earth
to cause to inherit the desolate
heritages
that thou mayest say to the prisoners go
forth to meet them that are in darkness.
Show yourselves. Behold, these shall
come from far and low. These from the
north and from the west, and these from
the land of Sinim.
So, many people will accept the truth.
Mhm.
But, it's going to be sown in tears. And
this is also what is the
what the reason for the three angels'
messages is. It's a warning message.
Okay. Some people won't will accept it,
but probably the majority won't. All
right. Now, we need a little bit more
meat to this. We know now that it's an
everlasting gospel.
It has never changed.
It hasn't been modified.
It hasn't been minimalized, in other
words, to make it easier.
Mhm.
Deuteronomy 6:2,
"Fear God and give glory to him." Let's
see what this actually means.
"That thou mayest fear the Lord thy God,
to keep all his statutes and his
commandments." And this also comes out
of the first angel's message. Fear God
Yep. Same thing.
to him. So, what does it mean to fear
God and to give glory to him? It means
to keep his commandments. Yeah.
"Which I command thee, thou and thy son,
and thy sons all the days of thy life,
and that thy days may be prolonged." Can
you see now, Martin,
why only those who keep the commandments
can actually bring the message?
Then you're in harmony with what God
wants, with his message.
All right. So, if he says fear God,
then you have to show it by keeping all
of his statutes and his commandments.
Let's take another verse. Deuteronomy
8:6, "Therefore thou shalt keep the
commandments of the Lord thy God, to
walk in his ways, to fear him."
So, how do you show you fear him? Uh in
other words, respect him. That's it. Not
be afraid and shake and quiver.
Because we have a God who's come very
near to us, right?
Again, fear God is coupled with the
commandments.
Take another verse.
Deuteronomy 13:4.
"Ye shall walk after the Lord your God,
and fear him, and keep his commandments,
and obey his voice, and you shall serve
him, and cleave unto him."
Do we have the same link? Yes. And
now again, just for somebody that
might not have seen the episode on the
character of God, go and watch it.
This commanding the people
is not a
"Do you have to do this, either you will
be lost." It's actually a calling. It's
a call. It's a it's a
an invitation.
Invitation.
And then you have the summary in
Ecclesiastes 12:13, "Let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter."
"Fear God,
and keep his commandments, for this is
the whole duty of man."
So, Martin, obviously only those that
have an understanding of this issue
Mhm. can bring the message.
Those that do not have an understanding,
or that believe that the law's been done
away with, they cannot bring this
message. That's why they don't.
Yeah.
And that's why they're angry with those
who do.
So, to give glory to God is to reveal
his character in our own, and thus make
him known.
We have to show God's character
in our own character. That means we must
come into harmony with God's will.
Martin, you try and do that
in any relationship, you're going to
pick up trouble.
Yeah, yeah.
And in in whatever way we make known the
Father or the Son, we glorify God.
So, when we keep the commandments, you
are glorifying God,
and you are actually sending a message
without actually having to say
something.
Yeah.
"Yes, we are the Lord's blood-bought
heritage.
Whether therefore ye eat or drink, or
whatever ye do, do all to the glory of
God." Quoting 1 Corinthians 10:31.
This God requires of everyone who shall
compose his family in the kingdom of
heaven.
All selfishness must be overcome.
We must be true to God, true as steel to
his commandments.
Human beings frame laws and are very
zealous for their enactment. At the same
time, they transgress the highest law
from the mightiest sovereign.
This they attempt to make null and void.
They exalt the human above the divine.
"Shall I not visit for these things?"
says the Lord of hosts in Jeremiah 5:9.
Yes, God will reward reward everyone
according to his works.
Is this the situation and the status quo
in the world?
Exactly. We are
if you see the lawlessness,
exactly, you can see everything is
falling apart.
In fact, lawlessness is being exalted.
It is. And those who want to be
law-abiding are being ridiculed.
That's it.
Then there's another component to the
message, and that component says the
hour of his judgment is come.
Now, Martin, when does this message go
out?
After the 2,300 day
prophecy.
Prophecy. So, this goes out
after 1844, right?
Mhm. A very good
um
episode to watch is also
about the end times. He's end of days
and all of this to see precisely where
where that is. Okay. So, there is a
proclamation in this message
that the hour of his judgment is come.
Mhm.
So, it is time for judgment.
That precedes the coming of the Lord.
That is very important.
So, when he comes, his reward will be
with him.
Mhm. Not
Either for salvation or for
condemnation.
doesn't come and judge then. No.
The judgment is complete Mhm. when he
comes.
Daniel 8:14.
"And he said unto me, unto 2,300
days,
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed."
This is such a powerful verse.
Mhm.
What does it mean? Daniel didn't
understand it.
No.
And he was told to go and rest.
Yeah.
He will be asleep,
and it is for the future to unravel what
this means.
Well, now if he couldn't unravel it,
even after Gabriel explained everything
else to him, other than this little
portion, do you think others would have
trouble with it as well?
They They will. They even had the
trouble in 1844 and '43. Could there be
a misapplication until you finally get
to the point where it is unsealed?
Unsealed. That's important. All right.
Uh Daniel 8:26, "And the vision of the
evening and morning, which was told, is
true.
Wherefore shut thou up the vision, for
it shall be for many days." It's a
sealed vision.
Mhm.
So, they didn't really understand They
didn't understand what was to happen
after the 2,300
days.
Then the sanctuary should be cleansed.
What is the sanctuary that's going to be
cleansed?
All right. Daniel 9:21,
"Yea, whiles I was speaking in prayer,
even the man Gabriel" So, this is the
angel
"whom I had seen in vision at the
beginning, being caused to fly swiftly,
touched me about the time of the evening
oblation.
And he informed me, and talked with me,
and said, 'O Daniel, I'm now come forth
to give thee skill and understanding.'"
So, he explains most of the vision to
him.
But, this little portion is shut up for
many days. It's not It's for the future.
So, verse 24, "70 weeks are determined
upon thy people and upon thy holy city,
to finish the transgression,
to make an end of sins, and to make
reconciliation for iniquity, and to
bring in everlasting righteousness, and
to seal up the vision and prophecy, and
to anoint the most holy."
Now, Martin,
can anybody bring in everlasting
righteousness other than Christ?
No.
Can anybody make an end of sins other
than Jesus Christ? So, this is a
Messianic prophecy, right?
And And it is given as a prediction of
the Messiah's coming.
So, the 70 weeks have a beginning, and
they have an end. Now, we've dealt with
this prophecy in other places. We're not
going to deal with it in detail, just
giving a brief backdrop.
For further details of the prophecy,
you're going to have to look at a
lecture dealing just with this issue.
So, the decree to go and restore
Jerusalem went out in 457 BC. Mhm.
Artaxerxes gave the decree.
And then it tells you how these weeks
that were determined upon the Jewish
nation at the time were to be
uh divided up.
And it breaks it up into portions.
Mhm.
And in prophecy, a day
equals a year, prophetically speaking.
And it predicts the exact time when the
Messiah would commence his activities.
So, it gives a time frame, and from 457
BC,
it comes to 27 AD, Mhm. when the Messiah
would commence his work.
Yeah.
Now, in 27 AD, Jesus was baptized and
commenced his work.
That's it. Yes. Because he was born in 4
BC.
Mhm.
Because the Bible is very clear as to
when he was born, and our calendar is
not correct and even a children's
encyclopedia will tell you that.
So in 27 AD Jesus was 30 years old and
he commenced his ministry.
Then it tells you about the final week,
the final 7 years and it says after in
the middle of that week, that would be 3
and 1/2 years,
AD
he would put an end to the sacrificial
system. That's it.
Now the way Jesus put an end to the
sacrificial system is by his death. By
becoming the sacrificial lamb. Correct.
So the antitypical. So the antitype had
met the type.
But probation had not yet closed for the
people as a nation. Yeah. Not as
individuals, as a nation.
It would take another 3 and 1/2 years.
So this is the portion relating to
taking it to the Jews first. Yes. So
Jesus made it very clear that the gospel
was to be preached to the Jews first.
But 3 and 1/2 years after his
crucifixion
they stoned Stephen. Yeah.
And with the stoning of Stephen
Paul
was converted on the way to Damascus.
Yeah. And at the same time Peter
received a vision that he should go to
Cornelius who was a Gentile.
And Paul was called as the apostle to
the Gentiles. So after 34 AD the gospel
was not to go to the Jews alone but was
to go to the Gentiles. So their time was
up.
The time when they would be the sole
herald of the plan of salvation
ended in 34 AD and the gospel went to
the Gentiles.
So in other words from 457 BC to 34 AD
490 years in total 70 weeks 70 * 7
the gospel was preached in type
by the Jews only. In type meaning they
had the sacrificial system. They had the
sacrificial system which pointed to
Christ.
And then it went to the Gentiles.
And for a period another period because
the prophecy stretches over 2300
days
that prophetic time period ends in 1844.
Now what happened in 1844?
We had the first proclamation of the
three angels messages by a group of
people that came out of a great revival
amongst all the churches.
All the women and the Millerite movement
started it and the message started going
out after 1844
and the message was the time of judgment
is come.
Now at that time period in 1844 1843
it really started already.
They didn't fully understand what it
means the sanctuary will be cleansed and
they thought it was the earth so they
preached that Jesus was going to come
again.
But when he didn't come in 1844 because
there's nothing wrong with the time
period.
In 1844 many many things happened. We'll
look at it in a moment.
From that time onwards there had to be a
study as to what is the sanctuary
because Jesus didn't come
and they discovered the sanctuary
message the plan of salvation
encased in an enactment
which prefigured
the plan of salvation namely the
sanctuary. So they also
the unsealing
of that prophecy that that was told to
by Gabriel to Daniel that was sealed
Correct. We read about that all in
Revelation chapter 10. So let's read
here in the Great Controversy this
statement. The announcement the hour of
his judgment is come
points to the closing work of Christ's
ministration for the salvation of men.
You see if the sanctuary
prefigured the plan of salvation
then Christ's work must be a culmination
of that prefigurement.
Let's see what this means. So it heralds
a truth which must be proclaimed until
the savior's intercession shall cease
and he shall return to the earth to take
his people to himself.
Martin there are people that say
Jesus finished everything at the cross.
Yeah. Let's stop there. But isn't he
interceding on your behalf while you are
living? Of course. So he's still busy.
Isn't he working through the Holy Spirit
in your life to bring you into
conformity with his will? Okay.
The work of judgment which began in 1844
because it says the hour of his judgment
is come must continue until the cases of
all are decided both of the living and
the dead.
Hence it will extend to the close of
human probation that men may be prepared
to stand in the judgment. The message
commands them to fear God
and to give glory to him.
In other words they have to keep the
commandments. That's to fear God and to
give glory to him means to reflect his
character
which is embodied in the commandments.
And worship him that made heaven and
earth and the sea and the fountains of
water. The result of an acceptance of
these messages is given in the word here
are they that keep the commandments of
God and the faith of Jesus.
In order to be prepared for the judgment
it is necessary that men should keep the
law of God.
That law will be the standard of
character in the judgment.
That's the message part of the message.
Important. That's the standard.
That's what judgment will be
based on. Correct.
All right. Now let's go back to that
verse Daniel 8:14. And he said unto me
unto 2300
days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed.
Now in Jewish thinking if you speak
about the sanctuary they think about the
sanctuary of Moses and about the temple
that Solomon built. Yes. All right and
that was later restored.
That physical building. Correct. And
this is what the sanctuary of Moses that
Moses had constructed looked like. It
was also called the tabernacle. Yes. In
Hebrews 8:1
we read now of the things which we have
spoken this is the sum.
We have such a high priest who is set on
the right hand of the throne of the
majesty in the heavens a minister of the
sanctuary and of the true tabernacle
which the Lord pitched and not man. So
this distinguishes it. All right. So
here's a very particular message.
So this earthly sanctuary the one that
we see here on the screen is a
representation
of another one that God erected in
heaven.
And it tells us about the plan of
salvation.
So in other words there was one opening
here in the front
and you had to enter into that.
And the Bible tells us Jesus proclaims
himself as the door. Yes.
He is the door and nobody comes to the
Father except by him.
So when you accept Jesus as your savior
you enter
by him.
And immediately you are surrounded by
this wall of white linen which
represents righteousness.
He's righteousness. He's righteousness.
So you are covered by his righteousness.
You are confronted by the altar of burnt
offering
where a lamb was sacrificed which
pointed to him.
And the blood flowed
and your sins had been transferred in
type to the lamb and the lamb died in
your behalf. That's the plan of
salvation.
And then there was a laver
where there was a washing a ritual
washing. This represents cleansing and
baptism.
And then there was a holy place a
chamber in which there was a table of
showbread
in which there was a candlestick and in
which there was an altar of incense.
Now Jesus said we must eat his flesh and
drink his blood.
We must eat the bread that comes down
from heaven which is the manna.
So here you had the showbread and there
were 12 of them representing the 12
tribes the 12 apostles. There were two
piles
and you had to partake of this and the
Sabbath was very important because
that's when the change of the bread took
place. The manna fell only six days and
a double portion on the sixth.
Correct. And on the Sabbath there was
none.
And then there was the candlestick Jesus
the light of the world. But I also want
to say that the bread the manna that
came down from heaven also represents
Christ that came from heaven to earth.
He came down and he said you have to eat
my flesh and drink my blood. And many of
them went away because they couldn't
handle the teaching.
So Martin you have to partake of the
light of the world. I am the light of
the world said Jesus And the word is
light, so you have to partake of the
word, you have to eat the word, you have
to internalize it. And the altar of
incense is him making your prayers
acceptable to God, and the smoke
ascended up and went over the curtain,
and it came down into the most holy
place where the law was.
Yeah.
Now, the law is the one that condemns us
to death, but it is most holy. Yeah.
Now, the condemnation was shielded by
the mercy seat,
Mhm.
which was above the law, which is
actually the throne where God sits,
where he's seated.
So, the whole plan of salvation is
enacted. You come in
to the door.
You accept Jesus, you accept the
righteousness of Christ to cover you,
you accept his atonement, you are washed
in the washing of rebirth, you
internalize the word, you eat the word,
you pray to God, and you come into
harmony with the law, but you are
shielded from its condemnation by Jesus
Christ himself.
Which the mercy seat represents him
again. Correct. And if you do not have
every component of this,
then you are in trouble.
That's a problem. And there was a daily
ritual
Mhm.
where the enactments took place in the
court and in the holy place.
But once a year, there was a cleansing
of the sanctuary.
Yeah.
In other words, the record of sin was
removed from the sanctuary.
It defiled the sanctuary.
Yes.
So, the day of atonement, the annual
cleansing of the earthly sanctuary,
prefigured the antitypical day of
atonement, or the final judgment of
humanity before the heavenly high priest
would cease his work in the heavenly
sanctuary prior to the second coming in
glory.
So, when that message went out, the hour
of his judgment has come,
Mhm.
literally what it was saying was we are
now living from now on in the
antitypical
day of atonement. It is the time of
judgment. It is the time to make right
with God, to come back into harmony with
God, to live a particular lifestyle, and
to live according to the directives of
God. Can you maybe just expand a bit
just explain what the
Jewish people had to do during that that
antitypical day of atonement before the
day of atonement actually came about?
They had to cleanse themselves. What was
the period? Was there time period? Was
it a day?
It was a day.
It was the day of atonement. All right,
so they had to prepare and afflict their
their souls.
In other words, they had to investigate
their motives.
And whatever was wrong had to be
righted.
They had to fast on those days.
They did not partake of their normal
diet, for example.
They they fasted. They abstained from
food, such as flesh foods, for example.
And they had to investigate themselves
as to whether they were in harmony with
God or not. So, this is what God expects
in the time of judgment.
If we go to a hymn that was written by
Uriah Smith, "O Brother, Be Faithful",
we read the words, "O Brother, Be
Faithful, Soon Jesus Will Come,
for whom we have waited so long.
O soon we shall enter our glorious home
and join in the conqueror's song." This
is a song that was written in this time
period. This was the expectation of
those who preached this message.
"O Brother, Be Faithful, Well, why
should we prove unfaithful to him who
had shown
such deep, such unbounded and infinite
love, who
died to redeem us his own?"
So, this was the mindset of those that
preached the message. Shouldn't it be
ours? Mhm. It's They were getting ready
for Christ to come because they was were
thinking he's coming to cleanse the
earth. Correct.
exact same hope now. All right.
Now, another aspect, besides the time of
his judgment has come, was worship him
that made heaven and earth and the sea
and the fountains of water. I mean, the
first angel's message is is very
comprehensive.
Yeah.
And it's hard to do justice to it in one
short period.
1844.
Charles Darwin and the origin of
species. This is his book, The Origin of
Species, and this here is what is
written in the forward.
It says, "Some light on the origin of
species,
that mystery of mysteries, as it has
been called by one of our greatest
philosophers.
On my return home, it occurred to me in
that something might perhaps be made out
of this question
by patiently accumulating and reflecting
on all sorts of facts which could
possibly have any bearing on it.
After 5 years' work,
I allowed myself to speculate on the
subject and drew up some short notes.
These are enlarged in 1844
Mhm. into a sketch of the conclusions
which then seemed to me probable.
From that period to the present day,
I've steadily pursued the same object. I
hope that I may be excused for entering
on these personal details as I give them
to show that I have not been hasty in
coming to a decision."
It's interesting in the same time period
when there was this great awakening,
Mhm. there was this awakening on the
other side.
Exactly. And the conclusions
that evolution
was to be accepted as an alternative
view to creation
was formulated in 1844. Is that
coincidence, Martin?
No.
No, the devil was right on
because the God's prophecy said that you
must give glory to the creator. All
right. So, here worship him that made
Made.
the earth
and the sea and the fountains of water.
So, Martin, here is what this angel has
to say. In other words, this message has
to go to the whole world, and at the
same time, another message is going to
the whole world, "No, you are the
product of chance and evolution."
Completely different. Two opposites.
Now, the other interesting thing is that
this portion over here
is also found in the law of God. That's
it.
So, if you go to Exodus chapter 20,
verse 8, it says, "Remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy. Six days shall you
labor and do all thy work, but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
thy God. In it thou shalt not do any
work,
thou, nor thy son, nor thy daughter, thy
man-servant, nor thy maid-servant, nor
thy cattle, nor thy stranger within that
is within this in thy gates." Is it for
everyone?
Everyone.
Just for the Jews? It is
No,
the stranger as well. Ah.
For in six days the Lord made heaven and
earth, the sea, and all that in them is.
It's the seal of God, Martin, here.
Here it is.
And it's part of the first angel's
message. Part of the first
And Satan has a counterfeit. That's it.
At the exact same time.
And he rested on the seventh day,
wherefore the Lord blessed the Sabbath
day and hallowed it. The first angel's
message is phenomenal. And it also shows
to you who's the creator. Yes.
And we we clearly saw that in the
previous um
slides, Jesus Christ.
So, let's just go to Exodus 31:16.
"Wherefore the children of Israel shall
keep the Sabbath,
to observe the Sabbath throughout their
generation for a perpetual covenant.
For it is a sign.
It is a sign. It is a mark. The word
there is oath. It is exactly that word,
which means a mark, a distinguishing
mark, a sign,
an enzyme, if you like,
Mhm. between me and the children of
Israel forever. For in six days the Lord
made the heaven, the earth, and the
seventh day he rested and was
refreshed."
Ezekiel 20:12.
Ezekiel is talking about the great
apostasy that took place amongst the
Israelites.
He was the prophet that was called to
explain why they went into exile.
And he laments, and he says, "Moreover,
I gave them my Sabbaths to be a sign
between me and them that they might know
that I am the Lord that sanctify them.
Hallow my Sabbaths", it says in verse
20, "and they shall be a sign between me
and you that you may know that I am the
Lord your God." You cannot separate the
Sabbath
from the law,
and you cannot separate the law from the
everlasting gospel. So, you cannot
separate the Sabbath
from the everlasting gospel. No, you
cannot separate it from the law, you
cannot separate it from the everlasting
gospel.
And if the law is the standard of
judgment, you cannot separate the
Sabbath from the standard of judgment.
No.
It's a very comprehensive message.
So, Martin, if the Sabbath is a sign
Mhm.
of God,
and in another portion of scripture it
says, you must keep the Sabbath
because thereby you acknowledge that he
is the one that sanctifies you.
Yeah. Right? Ezekiel says the same
thing.
So, your sanctification
comes from God and the Sabbath is a sign
of acknowledgement that you have
accepted it.
Acknowledging his authority.
And the Sabbath is a sign or a
distinguishing mark.
Does the enemy also have a mark? Yes. A
distinguishing sign? If he, like you
just showed us,
in 1844 when the first angel's message
says, "Give glory to the creator." He
gives you a separate message and says,
"No,
it's evolution." Obviously, he will then
come in with the
counterfeit of her. And it's interesting
that
the the Big Bang Theory, for example,
uh emanates from the Jesuits. It comes
from the beast.
And uh Pierre Teilhard de Chardin is the
one that pushed the evolutionary agenda
at the United Nations. So, this is
Babylonian wine. Martin, we have to come
to the Babylonian wine because that's
part of the second angel's message.
And if you do not accept the first
angel's message, then you will be
particularly warned again by the second
angel's message.
And if you do not accept the second
angel's message, then you will receive a
third angel's message.
Yeah. Martin, the thing is, the if you
don't accept the first angel where we
already showed here clearly the mark of
God,
then you're going to have trouble later
on in the third angel's message with the
mark of the beast. Correct. So,
let's just sum this up.
The first angel's message has to go to
the whole world.
It is a message flying in the midst of
heaven. It has to reach absolutely
everyone. Right? Mhm. It has to again
proclaim the everlasting gospel.
In other words, to put the jewels in the
proper settings of gold.
And to bring the whole gospel, not half
a gospel, because the whole gospel
is yes, you accept the atonement of
Jesus Christ. Yes, you are saved by the
righteousness of Christ and the
righteousness of Christ alone, but the
outflow
Mhm. is that you allow Christ to work
within you and therefore you will keep
the commandments.
Yeah. That's the whole gospel. You ought
to be saved from your sins, not in your
sins. There has to be a conversion.
And we are living in the time of
judgment. We are living in the
antitypical day of atonement when the
record of sin will eventually be
removed. And when it is removed, you
want to be part of those that have been
redeemed where the record has been done
away with and you stand before God as
though you had never sinned. That's
amazing.
And Jesus Christ made all of this
possible. And in order for him to lay
down his life and take it up again, you
must worship him. Because he's God.
Like
Thomas said, you must worship him like
Thomas said, "My Lord and my God."
Yeah.
And you must accept that he is a not a
created being and you must accept that
through him and by him were all things
created and without him was nothing
created. And in the beginning was the
word and the word was with God and the
word was God. You have to accept the
full package of salvation.
And if the churches refuse the full
package and want to run with a half
gospel,
they will receive another message.
Mhm.
And that message, of course, went out as
well, but we will speak about that the
next time. So, when you're confronted
with all of these things, then you have
to make a choice.
And the choice is the same
as was in Joshua's day.
Joshua 24:15,
"And if it seems evil unto you to serve
the Lord, choose thee this day whom ye
will serve."
"Whether the gods which your fathers
served that were on the other side of
the flood or the gods of the Amorites in
whose land you dwell, but as for me and
my house, we will serve the Lord." Are
we going to follow the dictates of men
or are we going to follow the direction
of God, which is manifest in his word.
in his word.
Martin, perhaps
I can turn to
Hosea.
Let's go to Hosea.
And we'll end with Hosea.
Hosea comes just after Daniel.
Martin, this was a message
that was directed at God's people at
that time.
And it was a very serious message. It's
a message that's very much like the
first angel's message.
You either accept this message
or there will be consequences, right?
Yeah. Okay, so let's read there in Hosea
chapter 4 from verse 1.
"Hear the word of the Lord, ye children
of Israel.
For the Lord has a controversy with the
inhabitants of the land
because there is no truth Mhm. nor mercy
nor knowledge of God in the land."
Have we reached a similar point? I
believe we have.
How many people don't understand God? Uh
the majority. Wasn't that what our last
one was all about? People don't
understand God. Even as it was
screening,
the people's comments, it was clear. It
was clear they didn't understand God.
They don't want to study the character
of God. They don't want to. And there
was there was one in particular that was
saying that God is responsible for
slavery.
Yeah. Now, Martin, I asked myself at
that point and I was so itching to
answer,
if God was responsible for slavery, why
did he save a whole nation out of
slavery? Why did he come to save
humanity out of slavery?
All right. Now, why did God permit
slavery?
You see, people don't understand.
Because he permitted it, he gets the
blame for it. He didn't do it.
No. But he didn't take it away. Why
didn't he take it away? Because we had
to learn a lesson from it.
And the lesson had to be learned in a
hard way. In the United States, didn't
it lead to a civil war?
Yes.
And how many churches were actually
against slavery?
Isn't it interesting that only the
Seventh-day Adventist Church and one or
two other denominations
were actually voicing the their concern
and saying that slavery is wrong
according to the scriptures.
Because the others were using the Bible
to justify
They were using it to justify it.
Because they had a misunderstanding of
God's character. All right.
And the Oh, So, there's no knowledge of
God in the land.
I think we have the same situation
today. They think that God has changed
his mind,
has reversed his positions.
But he says, "I am the Lord, I change
not."
There is no consistency. Now, what are
they doing? What were they doing? By
swearing and lying and killing and
stealing and committing adultery,
they break out and blood touches blood.
What is the situation in the world today
when you switch on the news? Exactly the
same.
Isn't it exactly the same?
And even is there's no distinction. This
is even in the top, in the leadership.
All right. Okay.
"Therefore shall the land mourn and
everyone that dwelleth there in shall
languish
with the beasts of the field and with
the fowls of heaven, yea, the fishes of
the sea also shall be taken away." Are
we there? Yeah. Everything is Is this
happening here?
"Yet let no man strive nor reprove
another, for thy people are as they that
strive with the priest." They won't
receive rebuke.
Mhm.
They won't listen. Don't judge me.
"Therefore shall thou fall in the day
and the prophet also shall fall with
thee in the night and I will destroy thy
mother."
Mhm.
Prophetically, a mother is a woman.
Yeah. Therefore, she is a church. So,
And there must be a church that is
bringing false messages
and God is going to destroy her.
Right?
Yeah. Because the nations drink of her
wine. But let's not go into all of those
details. I'm looking at the condition
then and I'm comparing it to the
condition now.
And then it says in verse 6, "My people
are destroyed for lack of knowledge."
Knowledge of what?
The plan of salvation. They don't
understand the everlasting gospel.
"Because thou has rejected knowledge,
I will also reject thee
that thou shalt be no priest to me
seeing that thou hast forgotten the law
of thy God. I will also forget thy
children."
Martin, do they understand the
everlasting gospel? Did they understand
it?
No.
Are we in the same situation today?
I was just thinking if we go back to the
other
um verse,
all those the swearing and lying and all
that, that's breaking the commandments.
Correct.
This one again tells you they forgot the
commandments.
"Okay, as they were increased, so they
sinned against me. Therefore will I
change their glory into shame.
Martin, the world is in exactly this
situation.
And here is a warning from God.
And it gets to be very, very sad. Cuz if
you go to verse 11,
Mhm. it says, "Whoredom and wine and new
wine
take away the heart."
When we get to the second angel, they
are drinking wine. Yeah. The false False
doctrine. My people ask counsel at their
stocks and their staff declareth unto
them for the spirit of whoredom has
caused them to err. And they have gone
a-whoring from under their God. They're
listening to the dictates of men.
They're sitting in ecumenical councils.
They sacrifice upon the tops of
mountains.
They are mingling all the religious
systems as though they were all
plans of salvation.
Yeah. But you can't have a salvation by
works and a salvation by grace at the
same time. It's impossible.
Now, what are the consequences? It's
very sad. Let's drop right down to verse
17 and let's stop there.
Mhm.
Ephraim is joined to idols. Let him
alone. Yeah.
One of the saddest verses
in the whole of the Old Testament.
God had reached the point
where his children wouldn't listen.
And he said, "Ephraim is joined to
idols." That is like
your house is left unto you desolate.
Let him alone.
And what happened to the northern
tribes?
They were taken away.
Martin, this final message to the world,
this everlasting gospel,
is either accepted by the world
Mhm.
but it won't be.
I But it will be accepted by
individuals.
Yeah.
Within all the organized religious
systems of the world, there will be
individuals that will take heed of the
first angel's messages. So, let's not
stop preaching it ever.
And we have marching orders and that is
to proclaim these three angels' messages
and not stop.
So, we've given a brief summary of the
first angel's message. Unfortunately,
the second angel will have to follow.
Amen.
So, let's close with a word of prayer.
Our loving heavenly Father, you have
done everything possible
to save erring humanity.
You have pleaded with humanity. You have
shed your blood for humanity.
You are interceding on behalf of
humanity.
And soon that intercession will stop.
The hour of your judgment is already
here. It has already commenced.
And soon it will cease.
And then it will be too late and a
decree will go, "Ephraim is joined to
idols. Let him alone."
Lord, let not that decree fall upon our
heads.
We have a similar one in the book of
Revelation
where the same warning is given.
And people have to make a decision.
Help us to make the right one in Jesus'
name. Amen.
Amen.